[Musique]
j'étais vraiment un étudiant au cégep
ainsi qu à temps plein et j'étais en
sueur semaine j'avais un travail aussi
sur la rue saint-denis et avec la crise
en ce moment mais j'ai dû arrêter ce
travail-là après le coup vie j'ai
commencé donc à rester chez moi donc
j'ai perdu ma job j'ai commencé à faire
l'université à la distance et je pensais
à des moyens pour m'occuper
je m'appelle arnaud et je forme mes
courses équilibre chez vous je me suis
dit au départ comment est ce que je fais
pour premièrement aider les personnes
qui ne peuvent pas sortir de chez elle
comment minimiser leur sortie la
deuxième chose que je voulais faire
aussi c'était peut-être de trouver
quelque chose à faire pour toutes ces
personnes là qui ont perdu leur emploi
et qui veulent faire quelque chose de
leur journée et je me suis dit pourquoi
pas combiner les deux j'ai fait un petit
pamphlet sur internet puis gelé diffusé
à mes proches puis finalement ça a
commencé à grossir de plus en plus puis
c'est le cas justement j'ai réussi à
contacter jonas pigeonnant c'était
vraiment motivé comme moi je m'appelle
jonas et je prends les appels pour
livrer chez vous j'ai reçu un appel de
arnaud et il me dit j'ai commencé un
espèce de truc de livraison et jeu court
ça va pas et clients directement prendre
les courses les apporter au client comme
si on était cliente ses bons jours ces
jeunes insultant de hadera comme vous
avez raison
merci à vous pour une commande par apple
qu'est ce que vous voulez commander le
mode de carol je vais vous apporter son
savoir vers 3h secret pour vous le site
web est sorti et nous avons pu le
partager avec plein de gens notre
communauté
ma mère
on doit partager plein de mails tout ça
on nous demande un ami de la famille de
partager et finalement après deux trois
jours on avait cinq six commandes par
jour qui arrivait dans le fond une
organisation à but non lucratif qui
offre des services aux personnes qui
peuvent donner serment sortir de chez
elle aux appels de jeunesse à bonjour
pas mais là c'est vraiment gentil de
faire du bénévolat
si vous voulez on peut en parler pendant
un petit peu plus longtemps et tout à
l'heure parce qu'en ce moment j'ai un
petit peu occupé mais je peux vous je
peux vous rappeler vers 11 heures c'est
bon parfait attentes aubenas c'est en
cours ça y est on a trouvé beaucoup de
monde qu'ils étaient prêts à sacré de
leur temps prêt à sacrifier de leur
énergie pour justement aider les
personnes qui sont le plus dans le
besoin qui ont le plus besoin dead et
qui sont plus vulnérables donc justement
ça nous a vraiment fait chaud au coeur
il ça nous redonne vraiment de l'espoir
dans le sens qui est ce sont des
personnes qui sont là pour aider pis si
c'est vraiment c'est fantastique
les brouillons qui sont intéressés juste
à aider même s'ils sont payés 5 $ pour
la présence super île à bruz dans son
hyper motivés qu'est-ce que soit la
situation
bonjour je m'appelle billet et je les
fichiers vous l'aidez poids je leur
écris le message de commandes
j'ai juste à rajouter à la fin c'est une
belle personne qui a besoin de toi
où elle est handicapée vienne
l'impression profil et direct la
personne me répondit je veux ça motive
les gens d'aider des gens qui en dix ans
pour moi le plus gros défi c'est
vraiment de sites ou de l'organisation
de administratif de la chose là parce
qu'avec aide à la communauté livraison
on doit d'abord répondre aux demandes
des gens et puis que ce soit des clients
que ce soit des coursiers potentiel ou
d'autres organisations qui veulent avoir
affaire à nous donc il faut qu'on
communique constamment avec les gens oui
allô oui donc pour un cours si c'est
vraiment simple si jamais il ya un
problème est tel que par exemple si un
client par exemple le demandent et des
poivrons verts mais qui ajuste des
poivrons rouges à l'épicerie et bien
vous allez devoir trouver un compromis
avec le client ils sont récompensés de
l'étudiant en relations industrielles
le suite à cette expérience pense que
j'ai plus de potentiel dans ce qui est
seulement en entrepreneuriat quelque
chose de comme gérer une entreprise ou
faire du management
moi j'ai plus l'impression que
l'entreprise a des chances de durer au
delà de la glisse
[Musique]